perhaps someday in the far future we'll
be telling our grandkids about how
restaurants once had human servers
instead of ordering from a kiosk or a
phone a flesh and blood employee would
come to your table offer recommendations
and take your order so old-fashioned
right yes it seems like many of the Food
Service Technologies popularized during
the pandemic are sticking around even
though the majority of Americans are
vaccinated and we've largely gone back
to eating masculus indoors we're still
scanning QR codes and scrolling through
digital menus why is that of course
covet is still with us and still poses a
threat to vulnerable people but we now
know that you're far more likely to get
it from the air than a piece of paper
the reason we haven't reverted back to
pre-pandemic dining Trends has less to
do with epidemiology or even technology
than economics specifically labor
economics
[Music]
it's been called the Great resignation
the great renegotiation or the great
reshuffle and it refers to an
unprecedented spike in Americans
voluntarily leaving their jobs beginning
in early 2021 at first some politicians
were quick to accuse people of being
lazy opting to live off government
handouts rather than work for a living
but as the picture became clearer
economists found that most quitters were
not leaving the workforce they were
looking for a better job and for a lot
of them it worked in many regions
Workforce participation is back up to or
even higher than it was pre-pandemic
wages have risen virtually across the
board although inflation has taken a
chunk out of that and many workers find
that they have more power and
flexibility at their jobs than they did
before however there are a few sectors
still still struggling to fill vacant
positions and hospitality is at the top
of that list as of the summer of 2022
food service employment is still six
percent below pre-pandemic levels there
are two big reasons as non-essential
businesses many restaurants close their
doors at the beginning of the pandemic
since their employees were some of the
first to be laid off for furloughed they
were also the first to find new jobs
many in burgeoning sectors like Tech and
Logistics when the restaurant industry
finally started to come back they found
that their employees didn't want to come
back
that leads us to the second big reason
these jobs were never that good to begin
with low pay unpredictable schedules
lack of benefits and advancement
potential many of the people who used to
work in the food service industry prefer
their new jobs more quoting higher pay
and flexibility as the most important
factors but wait if these jobs weren't
so lousy why did it take a pandemic for
cooks and servers to finally leave the
apron behind the short answer is that
the labor market is much tighter now due
to several factors not everyone who quit
found another job some started their own
businesses some went back to school a
lot of baby boomers saw the pandemic as
a good time to retire taking their
Decades of work experience with them
genzirs have less interest in Food
Service as a temporary job and more
restrictive immigration policies have
meant less migrant labor as well the
cumulative result is that there aren't
enough applicants to fill all the
available positions giving workers more
leverage and choice that's great for
workers but rough for the industry and
it creates a destructive spiral short
staffed restaurants ask their employees
to work harder customers are less
satisfied giving more complaints and
fewer tips as the job becomes less worth
it more people quit and the problem gets
worse employers are aware of the dilemma
and many are putting their faith in
technology as the magic solution QR
codes online menus phone payments robot
servers anything that can cut down the
number of humans on staff is being
implemented there are even some
artificial intelligence Technologies
being developed that can say understand
a customer's spoken order at a
drive-through or predict what
ingredients to order from vendors to
minimize food waste according to one
survey more than 75 percent of eateries
now use at least three automated tools
and the restaurant management software
Market is expected to grow by almost 16
annually over the next decade but not
everyone is on board some food service
employees say that working alongside
Tech makes the job harder not easier not
all customers have smartphones and some
that do aren't comfortable navigating
technology servers often have to play
the role of tech support and may receive
smaller tips from irritated diners
mobile ordering also encourages
customers to make more additions and
special requests while expecting
machine-like speed and accuracy servers
and Baristas who once prided themselves
on their interpersonal skills now feel
like dehumanized vending machines it's
not very pleasant for the customers
either a study done by social
psychologist Ryan Dwyer found that cell
phone use during social interactions
like shared meals decrease the enjoyment
of the experience for everyone and we
all know that using your phone for one
thing like ordering a drink can easily
spiral into checking your email replying
to texts and scrolling through insta
there are other unforeseen consequences
of restaurant Tech many of these
automated systems like the rest of the
internet collect data about you and your
eating habits and share it with
advertisers some industry experts see a
future where your menu is tailored
specifically to you with prices that
fluctuate depending on what's available
or nearing expiration while it could be
handy to have a menu that remembers your
food allergies surge pricing for meals
has been met with pretty Fierce backlash
where it's been tried imagine seeing
your steak dinner go on sale right after
you've finished eating it besides eating
out isn't just about acquiring a meal as
efficiently as possible if that's your
priority you're better off ordering in
as we said in a previous video you're
paying not just for food but an
environment in which you can have
meaningful human interactions some
restaurateurs still believe that the
classic dining experience is what
customers are looking for and the only
way to save it is to make the jobs more
attractive to perspective and current
employees that can mean paying higher
wages allowing more flexible schedules
and offering benefits and perks but at a
time when 53 percent of Americans have
already kept back on dining out when
food costs are up by 17 and 41 percent
of restaurants can't even afford the
rent where will they get the money to
pay employees more some are raising
their prices others shrinking their
menus or shortening their hours and many
say that investing in an experienced
staff is actually more cost effective
turnover is expensive you can end up
spending more on training and
recruitment than on the perks it would
take to retain valuable employees no one
knows what will happen to the industry
but the next couple years are likely to
be transformative perhaps dining in the
future will be like stepping into an
automated vending machine or maybe
careers in food service will finally get
the respect and compensation they
deserve or a potential recession could
erode Labor's bargaining power are and
restaurants will go back to business as
usual like most economics it's a
question of values how much do diners
value the traditional restaurant
experience how much do employers value
their employees and how much do we all
value face-to-face human connections and
that's our two sense
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description to become a two cents
Patron
for more on how the pandemic affected
small businesses check out our video can
the food service industry survive
Coronavirus
[Music]